This program is being presented to you
by the Heras International Winter School
on Gravity and Light.
Welcome to the fourth lecture of the
winter school. We're now considering
differentiable manifolds. And uh so far
we looked at topological manifolds
and a topological manifold roughly
speaking allowed due to the topology on
it. Anyway the definition of continuity
of a curve and if you think of space and
you think of this curve as the
trajectory of a particle uh in classical
physics you certainly want to talk about
continuity and you want to require that
this curve doesn't make jumps. uh we
already achieved that. Now roughly
speaking you want more you want also to
associate to this curve at every point a
velocity.
That's the basic idea. Now it's pretty
clear that if the curve looks somewhat
like this then you have difficulty
associating a velocity here because
there's no unique tangent vector very
roughly speaking. Okay. The question is
can what's the difference between this
curve and this one? Well, roughly
speaking, intuitively you say this one
is a differentiable curve and this is
not differentiable.
But now we need to make this precise and
the question is is the structure of a
topological manifold MO. So we already
assume it's a special topological space
namely a topological manifold of
dimension D. The question is is the
structure M O enough enough to talk
about differentiability of curves and
the answer will be a resounding no it's
not enough can you construct from it a
notion of differentiability no of course
not that's what I mean it's not not it's
not good enough not enough information
you need to make more choices before you
can actually talk about
differentiability of a curve and in this
lecture will figure out what the amount
of this choice is and how much choice
you really have. I tell you already now
in dimension one two and three you have
choice but they're all equivalent. So
you have only one choice in one two
three it's pretty clear I mean one to
threedimensional topological manifolds
you have essentially one choice how to
talk about differentiability of curves
on them 1 2 3 dimension five 6 7 8 9 10
and so on so not four five six but five
6 7 you have in each dimension a finite
amount of choice okay so you say well
you have 48 choices Well, write it down,
do physics with it, make experiments and
you will find out which of the one it
is. Unfortunately, there's a theorem
which I will quote in the end that in
four dimensions, the dimension of
spacetime, you have an uncountable
number of possible choices.
Do you still think it's obvious which
one to choose? It is not. It's important
to figure out what is going on. Okay, so
this lecture is about figuring out what
structure we need to add on a
topological manifold in order to start
talking about differentiability of
curves on a manifold, about
differentiability of functions on a
manifold, even about differentiability
of maps from one manifold to another
manifold. We will need all this. Okay.
So we wish to
define
a notion
of differentiable
objects, more concretely curves.
What was a curve? Well, on a manifold, a
curve is a map from R to M uh of
differentiable
functions. uh that's just the
terminology for a map from the manifold
into the real number say a temperature
distribution on the manifold and most
generally maps
um from one manifold
to another. So I will now not always
specify that there is a topology on here
because I say it's a topological
manifold you know that is in the
background has been chosen. We want to
define such a notion. Now first what is
our strategy for that
and in the
third no in the second lecture I already
indicated what the strategy would be. I
spell it out once more. The strategy is
if this didn't happen if we didn't look
at a curve in the manifold. Let's start
with curves. So if we didn't look at
this guy in the manifold, but we rather
looked at a curve from R to RD, we would
know what we mean by differentiability,
right? And we could use the
undergraduate definition
and talk about that. Now the point here
is the strategy is um choose
a chart
UX. Well, a chart will not cover the
entire manifold, but let's start in a
chart and consider the portion of the
curve that lies in the chart domain.
You can say, well, that's not what we
want. We don't want the portions that
lie in a chart domain. We want the full
curve. But let's do it in charts. And
because charts domains cover everything,
we then can then compose the global
notion from the local notion. That's the
strategy. We try this and we'll see how
it works. Okay, but now how can we do
this? Well, if we have a chart, we also
have a chart map. We land in X of U in
RD. And here of course we got already
last time the object X after gamma which
is now a curve from R into RD.
But as a curve from R to RD, we know
whether it's differentiable or not. you
take the derivative with respect to the
curve parameter component-wise or
something like this. Okay, your favorite
your favorite definition here. And the
strategy or the idea is
try I think the chalk is wet here. try
to lift
the undergraduate notion
of differentiability
of a curve
on RD
to a notion
of differentiability
of a curve
on the manifold. Right? We already had
the question last time. Well, here you
call it differentiability and then you
used to call this also differentiable
but this should be called undergraded
differentiability and this is called the
manifold differentiability. Okay. But
you try to define this by coming from
here. Now of course already the problem
uh or the question we encountered last
time is um can this be well defined?
Can this be well defined? Because after
all the curve doesn't know anything
about me looking at a particular chart.
It would be a very bad idea to assign
the curve a property that depends on my
taste.
So well defined is this well be defined
under change
of chart.
So in order to judge that we again draw
this picture um gamma the portion of the
curve that lies in U you use one chart
you go to x of you in
in RD but now another chart could have
another chart domain and it could have
another chart map both at the same time.
Now if the other chart domain is V and
the intersection between the two is
empty then one chart here one chart
there they can't be incompatible because
this portion of the curve has nothing to
do with that portion of the curve. But
if this is non-MP
then in the overlap region there is a
real problem because one chart map might
tell you yes it is differentiable the
down there the of the same curve of the
same object in the real world the other
chart map might tell you no it isn't.
Well if that happens that's catastrophe
because then our definition is no good.
So that means we look only at the
non-mpt overlap region. But then because
this is part U is part of the overlap,
you can of course still use the X to map
here. This will still lie in RD. And on
this part you have X after gamma. Now
another chart on this entire overlap
region using Y gives you Y of U
intersected V in RD. And you have
another chart map y after gamma.
And now the question is if I use here if
I say this is undergraduate
differentiable
and of course that's just my term for as
a map from R to RD. This is what I mean
by undergraduate differentiable. If this
is undergraded differentiable
question, will this representative of
the same curve in the real world be
undergraded differentiable in the other
chart? Well, uh we know we have a chart
transition function here y after x
inverse from here to there. That was
exactly the chart transition function.
And um let's write it down. So that's
this guy. Y after gamma is of course Y
after
um what do we do? Y after X inverse
after X after gamma. You can read it
this way. This is this one after this
one. Um but of course the composition is
associative. So you could write y after
x inverse after x after gamma. You can
think of it this way. Uh then you see oh
it's really this guy here by inserting
the identity. Whatever way you think
about it this is all true. But the point
here is this guy here you know is
undergraduate differentiable
undergrad
diff.
And in fact it's really a map from R to
RD.
This guy is a map from RD to RD. right
from some portion of RD to some portion
of RD
and you know however because it's a
chart in a topological manifold two
charts in a topological manifold what
you know with certainty is that it's
continuous
well you could also call it
undergraduate continuous because it's
continuous with respect to the standard
topology in RD
but now you see the problem the
composition of a differentiable map and
continuous map may be differentiable
but it may not be. All you can conclude
is that the composition here
uh is sometimes maybe
only continuous
not undergrad
differentiable.
roughly speaking because a continuous
sharp transition map can um uh make make
an edge like this right and it destroys
the differentiability.
So the answer is it doesn't work. It's
simply this does not work.
Now what is the remedy of the whole
thing? By the way, if you now want to
study this, the diagram looks very
similar and a similar problem occurs. If
you wanted to define the function on a
certain domain, you try to study how it
looks in as a chart represent chart
representative of the function and so
on. And here for these maps, the diagram
uh looks on both sides. You have to
choose charts here and there and the
diagram becomes bigger. But it's always
the same problem. If you change chart
and you only know that the chart
transition map is continuous as is
guaranteed by the topological manifold
definition, then you're in trouble. Your
strategy does not work out.
So at first sight,
strategy
does not work out.
But of course there is a remedy for the
whole thing and that's section two
compatible
charts.
So let's um make a bit more explicit
what we said before.
Um,
in section one
we only we used
any imaginable
charts
on the topological manifold.
M O
and um in order to emphasize I mean of
course a chart is a chart. In order to
emphasize that we took any charts
possible
we say the following to emphasize
this.
We may say
we may say that we took
U and V these arbitrary charts
from
the maximal
atlas
A
of M Oh,
again an atlas was just a collection of
all charts.
No, sorry. An atlas was a collection of
enough charts such that the chart
regions
overlap the entire manifold. That's an
atlas. The maximal atlas is an atlas
that has many more redundant pages.
Namely, any page you could put in is in
there. So the maximum atlas is a
theoretical object. I would never if I
want to give you an atlas I would always
write down a minimal or almost minimal
atlas at least a small atlas as small as
possible somehow because it saves work.
But then I can imagine you can ask does
an an additional chart lie in the
maximal atlas okay and the answer is if
it's a chart it lies in a maximal atlas.
Okay. So this is the and so we we say we
took U and V from the maximal atlas.
But some of these guys we might be lucky
maybe this maximal atlas can be reduced
such that I throw out all those charts
which have between them a transition
map. a chart transition map that is only
continuous but not differentiable
because the chart transition map is also
from RD to RD. We can use our
undergraduate understanding of the
differentiability and require that we
only keep a subset of charts
that we originally had in a maxon atlas
and we pick in a clever way such a
subset that it's still an atlas it still
covers but that all transition functions
are differentiable.
If we manage to do that, we make this
work by additionally requiring that in
the future you cannot just choose any
charts in order to define this in order
to define the um the differentiability
of this curve. You may only define the
differentiability of the curve from the
chosen charts from a restricted atlas.
But if you do this everything is fine.
Okay. So definition let's make this
formal this idea definition
two charts
ux
and vy
of a topological manifold. So first of
all of course it's any charts are called
flower compatible
If if
either
two possibilities if either their chart
domains do not overlap at all
somebody you don't meet you can't have
you can't be incompatible with right you
never got into trouble with you're
compatible with everyone you didn't meet
chart parts who have no common part of
their domains, they are compatible. But
now what if
there is overlap? So either or if
there's overlap, they're called
compatible if
either uh the chart transition map
between them. Now chart transition maps,
we got to be very careful. that two if
you have two charts you can do y after x
inverse was the one we wrote there y
after x inverse now what's its domain
its domain is the image of the
intersection and its target is the image
of the intersection under the other
chart map
that maps over there if the transition
maps this one and its inverse that's
this one x after x in y inverse
the The domain is y of u intersected v
goes to x u intersected v. Of course,
one is the inverse of the other. One
could maybe not write this and say,
well, you could rename u and v and x and
y and then it's contained. But it's
clear like this. If in both directions
these maps, these chart transition maps
are and now comes the point
because they're both maps from RD to RD,
right? Both maps from RD to RD.
I can use any notion of undergraduate
flower
property
in order to define flower compatibility
on the manifold. For instance, if I have
a notion of undergraduate on RD
differentiability,
I call two charts differentially
compatible.
If the chart transition maps are
undergraduate
differentiably compatible, if they're
differentiable,
if they have the differentiability
property. Okay. So, um why do I use the
ridiculous flower? Um the point is this
is the philosophy
that you can have different types of
manifolds and different types of
compatibilities.
Um
you define
uh an atlas
a
flower
is a flower compatible atlas.
If
um any
two charts in a flower
are flower
compatible
and then you say a flower manifold
is a triple
M O A flower
and of course the A flower must always
be a subset of the maximal atlas
because it's an atlas.
Okay, it still covers and that's a
flower manifold is a triple where of
course these two entries make a
topological manifold
but you have to choose a selection of
charts that are mutually flower
compatible whatever flower is for
instance differentiability
okay and that's a choice
and it's not clear for a given topology
ological manifold say the sphere
and I have the maximal topological atlas
can't I take out
charts in one way or can't I keep one
set of charts or another set of charts
that both satisfy the flower
compatibility
but the choices are not the same if that
happens and I wish to make a model of
space time
I should know which choice I make
because one is not the same as the
other. Under one choice, some curves
will be differentiable for instance and
other curves won't.
So I need to know and the question of
how many choices I can make is very
important in order to know whether I
introduce arbitrary assumptions here or
whether this is the only way I can do at
this level. Right? So this is for
physics. This is important. And this is
not mathematical sophistication for its
own sake. This is a really downto-earth
question for physics. Am I doing am I
choosing the right structure here? Now I
said it's the philosophy. Um let make
let me make a table
of what flower can be.
Yes.
May I ask a question for that? Why do we
require that the overlap between you and
we can also include the the zero overlap
in the definition of compatibility?
No, it's it's um you mean this one here?
Well, the zero overlap means it has no
overlap. Um so it would be the real
world. Um and there's one chart domain U
here and one chart domain V here. They
map this part of the world and this part
of the world. They can never cause an
incompatibility
in the definition
because there is no portion of a curve.
Say there's a curve in the world which
maybe even hits both domains. But then
one can only judge the differentiability
here. The other one can only judge the
differentiability here. But they can
never be in conflict. Hence if maps if
charts have nonover overlapping domain
if the intersection is empty
we don't have to worry they are
compatible but if they intersect then
you can judge the same piece of the
curve in one chart or the other and then
you may have a problem and there is
where the condition needs to be imposed
that's it okay so what can flower be
this is flower and this is undergraduate
flour
And of course this is silly but um
so um one thing we like to write
sometimes is C 0 are these C 0
compatible atlases what it means are
they are the transition maps are the
transition maps C 0 as maps from RD to
RD. C 0 means is the set of all
continuous maps
continuous maps with respect to the
standard topology on RD and you say
every atlas is a C0 atlas on a
topological manifold because the
transition functions transition maps are
of course continuous.
So is every atlas is a C 0 atlas. Now
you can ask is the atlas C1. What is C1?
C1 would be this. What is undergraded
C1? Well, it would be that the
transition maps as maps from here to
here. I mean strictly speaking from
where they are defined to where they're
defined. Right? Roughly speaking, um
sorry, with respect to O standard, um
this is these are the maps from R to D
to RD that are differentiable,
namely ones, and the result
is continuous.
You could have a function that's
differentiable, but the result is not
continuous. Okay, that's this. Of
course, you can generalize this to CK is
the function K times
continuously
differentiable.
Now you ask why do we insist on the
result being continuous? Well, you don't
have to. You could ask is it K times
differentiable?
But the nice thing about functions that
are not only k times differentiable but
the result is continuous is that you can
judge its k* continuous
differentiability
from the repeated continuous
differentiability in the in various
directions. So from the existence of the
partial derivatives and their
continuity, you can already conclude the
entire map has this property because
they're nice examples that maps are
differentiable k times uh
sorry there are examples for maps that
are not k times differentiable
as maps from RD to RD but all partial
derivatives are
right they're examples like this but
because it's nicer to not have to worry
about these cases you require the
function itself to be continuously
differentiable. Hence, this is a more
favored class of manifolds than those.
They're easier to work with. Okay. But
anyway, so you have this then there is a
class it's called C infinity. C infinity
compatibility means you can uh it's
continuously differentiable arbitrarily
many times. Okay, that's C infinity.
Then there is a case that's called C
omega. Omega stands for analytic real
analytic in this case. That means this
transition map can be tailor expanded
right uh a multi-dimensional tailor
expansion. So there exists a
multi-dimensional
tailor
expansion. Right? So in physics
sometimes people say well everything can
be tailor expanded. No, no, it's simply
not true, right? It's much stronger than
this one, right? This is so this is a
much smaller class
than this one. Okay.
And finally, uh maybe I I don't know how
how to call this um uh complex
differentiable or something like this.
Yeah. Um this you can do only for even
dimensional manifolds and you can
require that your chart map which is
from R2D to R2D
that they uh pair-wise satisfy the Koshi
Reman equations.
If you do that on top then you get
something called a complex manifold
which has much more structure than a
real manifold because you additionally
have the equation but you always ask
this of the transition functions. So by
imposing more and more conditions on the
transition functions you and why would
you do that? Well because you might want
to define a tailor expandable curve
but then you need an analytic manifold
in order to not destroy the tailor
expandability in one chart once you
transit to another one. So the more
fancy stuff you want of your objects on
the manifold, the more restrictive you
have to be in your choice of atlas. And
the question is yes,
the C omega whether I have just a
two-dimensional expansion or an
hundredth dimensional that doesn't
matter it's all C omega.
Uh no it would dep it would depend on
the dimension. So the question was
whether a um
whether it matters whether you have a uh
analytic function in one dimension or in
two dimensions. Well, they're totally
different functions. Okay. And in so you
can't even compare. You can't even
compare. But uh it's certainly not if
it's smooth this is called smooth.
Um smooth there are smooth functions
that are not analytic in any dimension.
Right? Okay. So this is the general
philosophy. So in the future if you hear
of a complex manifold you say ha it's
just here the koshi reman equations
apply to the transition maps you know
what a complex manifold is okay so so
this is the the general um overview here
um so that's what we what we want and I
think it's clear now from what I said in
the beginning I don't need to say it
again now our definition of
differentiability of a curve say our
curve can be called k times the curve on
the manifold can be called K times
continuously differentiable on a
manifold where I manage to find an atlas
that is a CK atlas because that will
preserve this property in one chart for
another chart. Okay. Now the question of
course is okay to what degree do
derivatives appear in physics? Okay, is
C2 enough? Maybe C3 to be safe or whatn
not. Um there is actually a nice theorem
by Whitney that says we don't need to
worry about this
theorem
without proof
any
CK manifold.
So remember that's a manifold that's a
topological manifold on which there
exists an atlas that is CK but K needs
to be bigger or equal greater or equal
than one so it's not for a C 0 manifold
of course right any CK so if it's if you
have a manifold for which there exists
an atlas where you can reduce the atlas
such that
all the charts that remain and still
constitute an atlas are at least once
continuous ly differentiable the
transition maps any such manifold um
uh sorry I should I'm sorry I should
formulate in terms of atlases and then
it's shorter and clearer
any ck
greater than equal one atlas
a ck greater equal one is his name of a
topological manifold
contains
as a subatlas which is still an atlas
uh a C infinity atlas.
Meaning if you have a topological
manifold,
there are some topological manifolds
where you simply cannot remove a chart
or charts in such a way that all that
remains is still an atlas and has
continuously differentiable transition
functions.
So some topological manifolds cannot be
given such a structure.
But those who can where I can achieve
that the transition functions are at
least once continuously differentiable
and I have an atlas in that atlas you
can remove more and more and more and
more charts this theorem says until you
have even a C infinity atlas. So the
difficult step is from a C0 atlas to C1.
That step is really substantial.
Right? This might or might not work to
choose such an atlas for a given
topological manifold. But once you
arrived here,
you trickle down right up to here.
Meaning in the future I will do hell and
specify which ck I will always use
smooth manifolds.
Thus
we may without loss of generality OBDR
we may without loss of generality always
consider
C infinity manifolds
and they have a name they're called
smooth manifolds
because that's nicer that's smoother
than saying C infinity manifold smooth
manifolds
Um, unless
we wish to define
tailor expandability,
um, complex,
differentiability
and so on because it doesn't trickle
down to here. Okay, but we don't need
this. Although as physicists sometimes
we would might may want to like this but
but then you really have to make sure
that your manifold your top underlying
topological manifold still allows you to
further reduce the atlas. So you see as
a physicist you cannot say a come on
let's tail expand a little right
just a little right
okay good good
so well it's already said but maybe once
a smooth manifold
is a triple M O A where this is a C
infinity atlas and this is a topological
manifold
and you see the only thing that
distinguishes a a smooth manifold from a
topological manifold is the provision of
extra structure but in this case it's
not extra because I put it on top right
but because I reduced it from a given
atlas but ripping out pages page 7 page
28 page 510 also contains information
because I could have ripped out the
pages. I could have ripped out other
pages and I send a message I love you or
I don't quite love you. Right? Um so
this is information choosing this atlas
because for me for is something like
physics this was this was always from RP
to R. This means this is one this is a
chart transition map.
It's a chart transition map.
Where does then the gamma has to come
from the experiment if gamma is really
infinite. Sorry. Gamma. What? What's
gamma? The the curve.
The curve.
No, the the curve. So again, the um So
the question Yeah. Okay. So the curve
the setup is the following. Um
so I throw this piece of chalk. Sorry.
Okay. Now it made a trajectory. Okay.
And I like as a physicist I think of the
trajectory that this piece of chalk made
in the real world. And I might with
sufficient idealization say if this is
the real world then what the chalk did
and I may think of this as time which
later on we won't but roughly speaking
this is the curve that the real object
in the real world made. And then of
course in order to communicate to you
because you just didn't look there but
looked out of the window. What did the
piece of chalk do? I set up a chart. I
put up little uh flags everywhere and so
on. And uh you will say it passed my
nose right here and you say it passed my
nose at that that time and so on. So I
set up a chart and you and then I give
you this here. I can write it down on
paper maybe even as a nice function. I
tell you this and of course once I set
up a chart this way I can write it down
this way. But as a physicist what the
chalk the trajectory of the chalk is not
this. The trajectory of the chalk is
that. Now of course if we write down
physics on paper I mean concrete curves
uh we'll always talk or almost always
talk
about this guy and you may change chart
and then you talk about this guy and so
on. But what we really think about and
the things really want should attach
um uh properties to or require
properties of in our model of the world
is this guy. what the the real path of
the real chalk and all this reminds you
is you may have a fantasy of saying well
but it was differentiable the curve I
wrote down to you uh well only because
we made very special provisions of not
choosing charts here that don't allow to
speak of that
yes let's assume I have a M and I lock
on to a b okay
this is a delta f is the third or four
the fifth derivative disc is continuous.
Okay.
How does this I I don't see how this
works.
Okay.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Uh well well the point
would be if I say I have you have a
smooth curve. So the question was I'm
sorry. So the question was what if you
have a pulse with a hammer you you
hammer on something and the fifth
derivative is discontinuous. So the head
of the nail makes it discontinuous. Um
well it makes
certain measurements.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well the point
is if you say world lines or
trajectories are smooth you would not uh
allow that. Now you can say I have a
smooth manifold but on a smooth manifold
I can define a C2 curve right. So if I
say I want this to be C2 so that if you
derive once more three times as you
required it's discontinuous that means
you don't require the curve is C
infinity you only require it C2
nevertheless you can still do this on a
smooth manifold with these transition
functions because C infinity after C2
will generically only be C2
right so it doesn't harm that you choose
a C infinity manifold if you still want
to consider for whatever reason curves
that are only C2 but not C3
and all the Whitney theorem says it
doesn't say the objects you look at must
then be C infinity it says it doesn't
harm the C2 objects if you choose the
manifold C infinity and you always can
okay
so therefore it's a good good question
because I maybe overstated before. I
said we can always choose our objects to
be smooth. We can still insist on them
not being smooth, but for the char
transition maps, I still require
smoothness and everything will be well
defined. Okay.
Okay.
Um
where are we? Ahomorphisms
and the theorem I mentioned in the
beginning.
So um last section diffomorphisms.
So I already mentioned that whenever you
have maps
from one set to another set and it's
just some map let's call it capital phi.
Um if you have no further structure to
the set you can say what you can study
the sets by studying maps between them
and um that's just maps they have no
further structure and what you usually
require is that the map is invertible.
So if you're on a on a naked set, so if
m n are naked sets, meaning you have no
further structure in mind, um the
structure preserving maps.
So not only respecting but preserving
maps are the bjections
and that those are of course the
invertible maps
for which there exists an inverse
because at a set theoretical level a set
roughly speaking consists of these
elements and if each element here you
can map to one here everything is hit
and none is hit twice you can pair girls
with boys and you know you you compare
this up and so two sets
may be such that they do have that they
exists such a structure preserving map
or not. So example
between the set one two three and the
set A
there exists no structure preserving map
at the pure set level because I can map
the one to the A and the two to the B.
But what do I do with the three? I would
have to map it to A or B again. But then
it wouldn't be by objective because no
inverse exists. And in fact you compare
the size of sets informally speaking by
talking about there exists a bjection
then you call the sets to be of the same
size. Well for finite sets that's maybe
a little bit overdone as a definition
but for infinite sets it works. So for
instance you can okay
um so that's an example where it doesn't
work. There exists no structure
preserving map. Now definition
a set M and a set N are called to be um
isomorphic
and I say set theoretically.
So I emphasize only if you look at the
set aspects they're set theoretically
isomorphic
morph is form and iso is the same. They
have the same form set theoretically
speaking only looking at their set
theoretic aspects. Therefore studying
them by maps by pure maps. Um they're
set theoretically isomorphic by
definition if there exists uh a bjection
fi between them. Well if there exists
one there exists usually many different
ones. The question is, is there at least
one one to one map?
If that is the case, then the one one
map is called an isomorphism, but the
sets are then called isomorphic. In
order to emphasize that this takes
nothing into account but the set
theoretic structure, we say they're set
theoretically isomorphic. And um
examples
are for instance the integers are set
theoretically isomorphic
to um the integers to the natural
numbers. They're as many integers as the
natural numbers. You say but they're
double as many roughly speaking apart
from the zero. No but you can make
pairs. Okay. uh bit more surprising is
that the fractions are as many as n and
there's this diagonal counting scheme
and so on. Maybe you saw this before. Uh
so they're set theoretically isomorphic
but n is not set theoretically
isomorphic for instance to the reals.
Okay, that's this example. Now that was
on the set theoretic level. Now and that
will always stay like this. Now we can
add structure to a set.
Um and we did this. If we add structure
to the set, we now consider still uh a
set but equipped with a topology. For
instance, we did this in the
first lecture.
And the question is can we define a
meaningful notion of topological
isomorphism
that will still because there are still
sets in there a topological two sets
will be topologically isomorphic. So
topologically
isomorphic
but there is a household name for that
and that's called their home
morphic and that's just traditional
language. It means they are at the set
level isomorphic.
But additionally
there exists
not only a bjection phi from m to n
but a bjection such that phi and its
inverse are continuous.
Why? Well, because continuity is the
structure respecting
property of these curves. So you add the
condition not only do I want these two
there to be a bjection, I want there to
be a bjection which in both directions
is continuous. If that exists, there may
be several those I call the two spaces
topologically equivalent.
And it's clear if two spaces are
topologically
isomorphic, sorry, topologically
isomeorphic or homeomorphic as one says,
then of course they're also set
theoretically isomorphic. This is a
stronger notion. I look at the sets more
closely.
Okay, so this is uh here
if you have a vector space you can do
similar stuff. You can call one vector
space vector space isomorphic to another
one.
If again you require the exists a
bjection fi between one and the other.
If it's a bjection
it means it's invertible and in both
direction it's linear because linear
linearity is the structure preserving
map here. And finally I want to show you
this is always the same principle. And
finally
what I actually want to do in this
section is I want to call talk about
difforphic maps. the definition
um two
um
um two C infinity manifolds
M O M A M
and N O N A N
are said to be
difforphic.
If there exists a bjection that's a
purely set theoretic thing byjection phi
from m to n
but because there's a bjection the fi
inverse exists such that the map phi
and the map fi inverse
are both
C infinity maps
and I haven't defined C infinity map yet
but it's clear how that goes. If you
have an M and an N
smooth manifold,
you may choose here an open set U and in
the target you may choose an open set V
and you look only at these portions of
this map. But here you can choose a
chart X and here you can choose a chart
Y and that goes to some RD. But this
here goes to some RE because if this is
a D-dimensional manifold where you start
and this is a E dimensional manifold
where you land the charge will have this
property and we like we would like to
call this portion of the map that lands
in that portion of that space. We like
to call it C infinity.
If the map y after phi after x inverse
which now uses a combination of two
charts here and there for its
definition. If this is undergraduate
if this is undergraduate c infinity from
rd to re of course you know the drill.
You need to check whether with
alternative charts X twiddle and Y
twiddle into RD and RE. You need to
check whether the other representation
uh Y twiddle after phi after um X
twiddle inverse whether this is also
undergraduate differentiable. But we
already know because we have a chart
transition map here and a chart
transition map here which because we
started with C infinity manifolds you
know the chart transition maps are
undergraduate C infinity and this
undergrad C infinity will be preserved
if I lift it up to here the diagram gets
bigger and the principle is always the
same.
Okay.
So why do I bother about diffomorphisms?
Well, if you look at a manifold and you
look so closely that you doesn't escape
you that it's a C infinity manifold. I
mean certainly it's still a topological
manifold but it's a C infinity manifold.
The question is can you distinguish two
C um C infinity manifolds using only
that structure. For instance, if I take
a ball,
I embed it and nicely and I pull back
the topology from R3. Right? So I take X
squ + Y M^² + N² + P ^ 2 in R3. I uh
induce the topology from R R3 the
standard topology. I get a topological
manifold. We already know right talked
about this. Um and then can I reduce
there the maximal atlas such that I get
a C infinity manifold? Yes, I um I I
promise you you can. Okay, so you have a
C in C infinity manifold. Now question,
you do the same but with 5 * M 2 + 7 * N
2 + uh 18 * P ^ 2 = 1 and then you get
an ellipsoid.
You do the same thing. You pull back
your topology. You reduce the atlas and
so on. Question, is there a
diffomorphism between this guy and that
guy? Yes, there is. Is there a
diffomorphism between the sphere and the
sphere where I make a little edge in it?
Right. I I fold it a little. Uh, no.
There is no diffomorphism between the
two. There is still a homeorphism
between the two. As topological
manifolds, they're the same, but as
smooth manifolds, they're already not
the same anymore. Okay? So, it always
depends at the level you look at it. But
still the surface of a potato that
doesn't have any folds, right? The
surface of a potato is difforphic to the
surface of the earth. Right? At this
level, unless you make a little edge
into it, at the smooth manifold level,
things don't have a shape yet. Apart
from not having little folds, folding
edges, but a shape they don't have yet.
That comes only later. Okay. So now uh
comes this uh uh theorem
that's the last thing theorem
is on the number
of
manifolds
of C infinity manifolds.
um one can make
out of a given C0 manifold
in brackets if any. So for some that
might not work but say you have one for
which it works
uh up to diffism.
So I can equip
a topological manifold with two
different uh um okay fine fine I first
state up to diffis. So if two manifolds
only differ by difforphism I count them
as one because through the differential
manifold perspective viewed they are the
same. Okay, up to the femorphism is the
following uh dimension of the underlying
topological manifold
1 2 3 and the number of different
manifolds I can make of that is one one
one
no ambiguity four I leave open I said in
the beginning five six seven here five
finitely many six finitely many seven
finitely
So this uh is the Moyes Radon
theorems.
So the point is this is not easy to
prove. Okay. And five six seven that
there are only finitely many. Uh this
has been shown by a field of topology
that's called surgery theory where you
have to learn how to glue together many
folds and stuff like this. Surgery
theory result. Okay. So extra techniques
had to be invented in topology in order
to prove this meaning don't worry if you
don't feel it. Okay. Uh it's it's a deep
result. And uh now four dimensions which
is of course as space-time physicists
we're particularly interested in.
There's some partial results that some
compact manifolds compact is a
topological notion. Okay. um the surface
of a sphere is compact but R2 as a
manifold is not compact as a topological
manifold right um anyway for compact
manifolds there are some where if the
Betty number is 18 it's also top
topological notion then there only
finitely many choices or something like
this some very very special exceptions
but generically generically and
particularly for non-compact manifolds
right which uh
is a real option for for spacetime.
There exist uncountably many
uncountably
infinitely many.
So not only infinitely many 1 2 3 4 5
but so many like the real numbers that
you can't even count them anymore.
Okay. And that's uh just an existence
proof. exist uncountably infinitely many
different
C infinity manifolds you can make out of
a given topological manifold.
So that's a real problem because which
one do you choose for physics?
Okay.
Number is it the same number for all?
No, no, no, no, no. It isn't.
And how finite? Two, three or 10?
Well, that doesn't matter.
Um, I don't know. I don't know whether
the the proofs actually only say I only
know the statement that there are
finitely many. I don't know whether
there's any definite number. Um probably
not because um these could look very
funny, right? And um some
five-dimensional ones might have 20 and
other fivedimensional months might have
28 different structures, right? So um
you can't really say what the finite
number is. Okay. I think I think I would
be very surprised if in dimension 28 the
number was 58 for all 20. It could be. I
don't know. I don't know. Um, but finite
still sounds fine. Okay, for a physicist
you could say let experiment decide,
right? Let's be real physicists. Let
experiment decide. But if you here want
to be a real physicist, you're also a
very busy experimental physicist, right?
So, so you see theory does something
here for you. You cannot always say let
experiment decide, right?
Okay. Thank you very much. See you
tomorrow. And in the tutorials, please.